I done for nine years working together
with him
he served overseas in some perilous
places but done some really cool great
way at wrangling people and getting them
together and getting stuff done
um very nice person if I was in a car
accident I'd call him to come rescue me
right
but also he is a master in Jiu Jitsu
um and he's skilled in many different
ways to choke a person to get them into
submission
so please welcome to the stage his bias
fake name Jake
all right thanks for having me here
today I'm from circus group we're a data
knowledge engineering Solutions company
and uh like Jared said I've worked in
government quite a long time like 23
years last 10 years I was a a government
surveillance I met my other two Founders
we came together trying to provide
Solutions we found out there was a lot
of data engineering solutions that were
relevant to government so I'm here to
talk a little bit about what we did
while we were in government and then
what we're doing now how that relates to
you guys
so as far as uh oh geez sorry as far as
geopolitics goes we think we're in a
critical point in history uh data is
really ubiquitous and it's really
eroding a lot of the national advantage
that we've had for quite some time uh
Jared likes to you know have this joke
with me that I'm like a proto-hipster
because I've been doing data since
before it was cool because I was in the
community uh but the reality is it's
like we used to have all of these
systems that just gave us data and we
didn't get data from the outside and now
everybody wants to get data from you
know commercial sector it's producing so
many different data products so
defense National Security leadership
says yeah we need transformative
Innovation uh you know to help strategic
competition
industry has been disrupted by data
products and most of that new thinking
that's coming out is like hey
give me more data well
data's you know like like Mark Twain
said you know data's like garbage uh
just add more data you know it'll be
fine
no I'm here to tell you it won't like it
won't be fine you need to have a plan
you need to know what your questions are
you need to know what your concepts are
you know this have a problem get data
for it syndrome is is not good
think through those Concepts think
through those questions turn those
Concepts into ways to constrain your
data and I'm saying all this and I'm
being a little bit preachy but
I've been there homie let me tell you I
am a sole professed data addict
I I would go and like this is one of the
projects that we did towards the end you
know get 40 plus terabytes of data I
would get Bank secrecy act data get
satellite data a whole bunch of
different data sets to integrate as a
solution I would go to a variety of
geographical back commands as part of my
my job it's a r d facility I worked at
provide them solutions they usually
didn't have data now I would try to find
something commercial and you know uh
engineer something that they could
utilize but you know it's not
necessarily the right path to just get
more data you need to come up with
something that will organize and
constrain that data and help you answer
the questions so in this one problem I'm
going to tell you about it's kind of
extreme case of way too much data but it
was it was purposeful we got over 40
terabytes worth of data no no images no
videos just text uh we we bought all of
what chain analysis had at the time why
because we're the government and we
spend lots of money you know we we we we
bought all the Bitcoin Litecoin ethereum
data Solana data that they had
integrated over three years worth of
container shipment data uh you know U.S
treasury Bank secrecy act data
had a bunch of different shipping
transactions cryptocurrency transactions
and lots of variability and structure we
had unstructured structured uh the bank
secrecy act data had 93 different fields
and each one of those uh each one of
those reports was actually an
investigation that a financial
institution submitted that was really a
roll-up of a bunch of different
transactions that they looked at for
maybe years and we had like I was like
90 million of them so a lot of
variability in data uh over a billion
distinct entities so
what we did is we focused on our
questions and then we came up with
constraints based on those questions and
we really focused on effects that we
were trying to generate with those law
enforcement partners that we had we were
doing money laundering operations at the
time so we looked at uh sanctions we we
know that we wanted to support law
enforcement you know drug operations
money laundering and then identifying
sanctions related activity so we really
focused in on how to create a structure
that would enable that so this is kind
of like a toy version of an ontology
that we created but you see there's kind
of variability in the in the entities
and the relationships that that were up
there
the point of showing this is this isn't
what was in the data this is what we
transformed the data into and we left
data on the floor like quite a bit of
data on the floor because this is the
stuff that we needed so we created you
know transformation pipelines to create
that you know top level ontology we
didn't want to be too prescriptive you
know there was lower level of you know a
lot more change to it but that upper
level is what we really focus on and
that was able to answer you know which
sanctioned entities involved in what
commercial Behavior what companies what
shipments uh and the relationships were
key if you look up there you have that
variability between yeah the person is
in this location but they've transacted
with this financial institution so you
can ask different questions and and be
able to answer hey what people are
associated with what company who shipped
these Goods to what location and what
sanctions program is that connected to
and all of that was available through a
graph tourism different type of query
that we ran so we did that so what
well it enabled more rapid targeting we
worked with one Geographic combat
command they had a a targeting shop they
would do it manually they would go
through not this data but some of it
they had some of the data and they would
generate a Target really every 30 to 45
days
one target
uh we got it down to every 30 minutes we
trained an analyst on how to do queries
in Gremlin and we said okay here's the
graph that we created uh go to town in
two weeks the guy did over 135 targets
and that 30 minutes wasn't you know all
the queries that he ran that 30 minutes
was like oh what is this I found
something is this a real relationship is
this not a real relationship were there
errors in that in that data Engineering
Process it was just really validating a
lot of those relationships so that
wasn't query time that was you know his
investigation to to identify and then
there was a lot of you know unknown uh
connections that were made and then you
know the government does what the
government does created a program office
and try to productize this thing and we
had bought a bunch of commercial
software so creative pipeline a bunch of
people were they're now doing this for
for all of uh defense support to law
enforcement and that's great but we came
up with these ideas and these processes
and we thought hey you know we can do
something with this there's this has
broad applicability and and that's
really what I'm here to talk about is
like if you go back to the effects
you're trying to generate and the
military is great because you know they
have all of these orders and these plans
and they write down okay we're trying to
disrupt these people and that's the fact
we're trying to generate but you know
even in your organization even even in
business you know they have
effects and and things they're trying to
do concepts that they want to identify
so I'm going to show you an example of a
commercial application of the same kind
of thinking and we created some software
that you know demonstrates this thinking
as well
um so I'll give you a toy problem that a
lot of services companies have you know
is the juice worth the squeeze right hey
I'm working for this person they're
giving me a lot of Revenue I'm doing a
lot of invoicing but you know what are
my expenses associated with that how
much money did we get for what we did
that's a common you know commercial uh
related problem so
we created this toy ontology that that
you see here
um and a lot of ontology is a little bit
more uh complex but have a more
hierarchy but they don't have to be you
know they can be really simple as long
as you're interrelating your data and
you notice those uh key differences in
the relationship types you know Services
you know belongs to works on and that's
reflected in the data and you know we're
taking data from four different systems
you know we have for uh notional ADP
data jira data Salesforce data
Quickbooks data stuff that doesn't
normally fit together you know you'd
have to download or hidden API uh
something like that to generate so what
I'm going to do is show you a video of
what we were able to do here so you see
that same ontology there on the left
part of the screen or my left ear right
that's what we're using to engineer the
data so we had already done the data
pipeline or we're going to show you a
query of uh you know what we're running
uh I guess it is you can see some of the
relation ships that we created
and zoom in on on one of those uh Fields
there
looks like we have a company Soylent you
know they had this uh Charlie Heston
Charlton maybe is what he goes by uh had
a project called different green tank
and you see all of the different
relationships there invoicing expenses
charge 2 belongs to and it's all showing
up as the the fields there on on the
right hand part of the screen
uh and I think we're going to switch to
a different uh query here in a second
and this is a very engineering heavy you
know solution engineering heavy uh
visualization this isn't meant for like
that final exploratory data analysis
product but this is just to verify hey I
did my engineering correctly so now
we're going to change some of that as
charge to every uh queries and then put
in Services related queries so you can
append that existing graph and and see
like okay I really did add in those
employees miles and and Arnie to that
cyberdyne systems uh project that they
were working something associated with
Terminators and then you know they had
uh bills that we invoiced to them okay
so you can see all of the relationships
there now that I've done that
engineering and I've looked and I see
okay I have all these relationships
let's get the data let's download it and
let's do something with it so that's in
essence what we did
so after we downloaded that
and I'm just going to zoom in really
quick so you can see now you'll see all
of those relationships together in that
table I know you guys probably can't see
but
there's invoices they're connected to
the different uh projects connected to
the different customers uh all together
in one consistent data product and that
consistency is actually really key if
you wanted to be deploying models on you
want a consistent data product
so going through the analysis back to
the original question and this is the
key part you're answering a question you
know that original question is is the
juice worth the squeeze you go to that
time spent on each customer table and I
did this in looker and a combination of
looker and Excel just to show this is
possible on that flat CSP that we
generated uh down on the right of that
time spent on customer table see
Glengarry Glenn Ross as you know the
person that or the excuse me the company
that the uh they spent the most amount
of time providing services to and if you
go to that percentage of revenue from
each customer on top
yeah that's the uh the biggest revenue
for that company but that client value
score
Glengarry Glenn Ross scores all the way
kind of towards the back and the number
one is this other company Soylent
and the point I'm trying to make is that
those relationships and that integration
and those questions
really matter to how you engineer the
data and how you do your data pipelines
and how you provide that consistent
product that you then deploy your models
to
another way of saying it is you're
trying to add context
and that context enables the
understanding and informs decision
making so this little triangle example
here is like showing you yeah you get
raw data and you try to create
information and meaning but the context
of how it relates to that individual or
that organization is really the part
that you have to implement so the raw
data in this case it would be you know
three backlit colors red yellow green if
you go to information and meaning like
okay that's a traffic light and that's
at the southern part of this
intersection
okay but the context and knowledge
related to that is I'm driving at that
intersection I'm driving at that traffic
light that's red I better stop
so you really need to have ways to add
in that context
and just have a plan for your data
know what questions you're answering
what effect that you're trying to
generate what's that overarching
strategic goal and and then
ask your data hey like what is it that
I'm trying to do with you you know maybe
the data that you have internal to the
organization isn't the right data that's
okay you can go get other data or you
can collect data within your
organization there are you know surveys
there are ways to go and procure data
Maybe the data you have isn't right for
the question and that's something that
you need to come through in in your
analysis uh data operations is a thing
you know data management data governance
data life cycle management combined with
content management and task management
that's something that you should do you
know we have a open source ebook that
just click the link go to it it'll show
you how to do it it's tool agnostic uh
it's out there uh we want people to do
it I was very happy to hear Rob
yesterday talk about how data Society is
doing it uh and and training people
please
do Implement some of those basic data
management skills data governance skills
but most importantly turn your questions
into Concepts and then use those
Concepts to constrain your data in some
kind of engineering formats you can get
a consistent data product that you know
will answer your question and and that's
really the point I'm trying to make is
bring those questions to your data makes
them make something that's not
necessarily like what the data is and
then transform the data to it and if
that data isn't the right data source
you'll have some kind of metric of value
because the most important thing isn't
the data it's your question it's the
Strategic goal it's the effect that
you're trying to implement
and that's pretty much all I had to say